وبهذا الاجراء الطبي اي زراعه نخال عظم
استطاعت الطفله الرضيعه فيفا التعافي من
مرض سرطان الدم الليمفاوي الحاد او
لوكيميا والبطل المتبرع هنا هي اختها
نازيه التي تكبرها بثمانيه اعوام والتي
اثبتت التحاليل انها الانسب لاجراء هذه
العمليه استشاري امراض الدم والاورام
وزراعه نخاع العظم في المدينه الطبيه بابو
ظبي الدكتور زين العابدين قال ان زراعه
النخاع كانت سبيل الوحيد لانقاذ حياه
عفيفه وبعد ذلك خضعت الرضيعه لعنايه طبيه
صارمه لمراقبه استجابه جسمها للخلايا
الجديده ومع الملاحظه تم التحقق من نجاح
عمليه الزرع بنسبه 100%
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
دوله الامارات حصلت عمليه الزراعه والحمد
لله رب العالمين امورها ممتازه وهذا الشيء
والحمد لله رب العالمين نقول حق الناس
قولوا ما شاء الله
محمد محمد مرحبا اليوم لما سمعت عن قصه
بنتك ماذا قالوا لك هل شعرت بالخوف من قبل
العمليه ما المخاوف التي كانت تراوتكم
هنا في الاستوديو اولا في البدايه عندما
سمعت بمرض ابنتي كنت خائفا جدا وكنت اشعر
بشيء من الصدمه انها صدمه للعائله لان
سنها الصغير كانت
عمرها ثلاثه اشهر فقط وكان هناك تشخيص
لاصابتها بمرض اللوكيميا او سرطان الدم
وفجاه انتشر هذا هذا الخبر وكان ذلك
بمصادم الصدمه واسوده الدنيا في وجهنا لم
يعد نرى شيئا اخر كنا نشعر باننا في وضع
سيء وباننا سنخسرها وقد تعيش وقد لا تعيش
وذلك بسبب هذا النوع الشرس من السرطان
الذي اصابها انها كانت حاله غير مسبوقه
بالنسبه لنا في العائله وبالنظر الى هذا
الوضع كان الوضع صعب جدا كان لعائله لم
يكن من السهل ان نفهم ولكن الحمد لله
مع
العنايه الخاصه التي تم تامينها لابنتنا
من قبل المستشفى والاطباء قمنا بتخطي كل
هذه المصاعب وهي شفيت الان وهذا جميل جدا
تبرع للرضيعه شقيقتها
هل نازيه واعيه انها انقذت اختها
نعم في الواقع عندما قال الاطباء بانه يجب
ان يكون بعمليه زرع ونقل نخاع
جلست مع الابنه
وشرحنا لها بان هذا الوضع معقد جدا شرحنا
لها كل شيء وهي كانت صغيره لدي اربعه
ابناءهم جميعا من البنات
والكل كان يريد ان يساعد الشقيقه الصغيره
ولكن التطابق اتى من هذه الطفله بالتحديد
وكانت سعيده جدا لانها هي من تنقذ
شقيقتها وهذا كان فرصه بالنسبه لها وانا
عرفت بانها التطابق بينها وبين الشقيقه
الصغرى كان تاما ذلك كانت سعيده وهي الان
مقتنعه بانها الشقيقه وكانها توام
لشقيقتها لم تبكي ابدا كانت سعيده